hi I'm Erik Bosse and we have a second
trailer for spider-man homecoming giving
us more info about Michael Keaton's the
vulture new details about spider-man
suit and by the look of it this entire
scene on the ferry okay don't worry guys
I'm sure there's even more to this scene
where the Joker tries to blow it up oh
crap just spoil that for you too sorry
now I covered a lot of this footage in
my first trailer breakdown but in this
video I'm gonna break down all the new
stuff and point out some interesting
details that you might have missed so
let's get started what's up guys
so starting things off we see how this
spider-man movie addresses the age-old
superhero problem of the skin-tight
superhero suit do you try to squeeze
into it quickly like Deadpool in that
recent no good deed clip do you wear it
underneath all your clothes at all times
like past Peter Parker's have done like
that sucks - I wear a thick unitard
under everything I wear just sweat
everywhere so spider-man homecoming has
come up with this brilliant solution a
loose baggy suit that shrink wraps
around Peter to become form-fitting like
those self tying shoelaces and back to
the Future Part two and I think one of
the appeals of this version of
spider-man is how they ground the
character in reality focusing on actual
high school issues and showing how a
real teenager would deal with this kind
of tag also I love the close-ups of his
adjustable binocular eyepieces
and web shooters as well as this midair
model pose that he strikes it's very
retro spider-man okay let's move on to
become an Avenger are there like trials
or an interview do me a favor can't you
just be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
[Music]
just stay close to the ground
you're the spider-man from you two so
here we come back to this scene with
Peter begging Tony Stark to be in the
Avengers
if you look closely you can see Peter
awkwardly recording this conversation
with this camera phone remember in the
last trailer Peter watched footage that
he took from that Airport battle in
civil war and I'm betting that this was
the same camera that he used to get that
footage like he's making a my time with
the Avengers highlight reel on YouTube
in facts Ned even mentioned seen footage
of spider-man on YouTube spider-man from
YouTube way to self-promote Peter and I
like Tony's response here can't you just
be a friendly neighborhood spider-man
obviously friendly neighborhood
spider-man is a spider-man catchphrase
in the comics and past movies and Stark
is using it here to try to keep
spider-man as a small-time local
superhero not one of the big timers who
have to avenge planets and guard
galaxies and we get to see spider-man's
version of that small-time life crashing
pool parties like this is an 80s teen
comedy let's be honest spider-man
showing up to your party is the best
yeah let's move on can you summon
anomaly of spiders oh yeah No
do you know him - stole a shield can
make sure the pseudo okay so I'm pretty
sure Ned it's gonna be the best part of
this movie and even though Ned Leeds is
a character who exists in the spider-man
comics everything about this character
from his look to his personality is
definitely gone CLE from the ultimate
spider-man comics and a lot of you have
pointed out that the whole tone of this
movie looks like it was inspired from
that particular comic series but I think
they're just avoiding specific names and
details because they don't want us to
expect a Miles Morales version of
spider-man but they should because that
would be great for so many reasons okay
then check out this Captain America's
Fitness challenge video that they have
to watch a gym class now this is
interesting because for one at this
point in the MCU timeline Captain
America is still considered a criminal
and a fugitive so this gym teacher must
still be on Team cap or maybe it's a
hometown hero thing like Queens school
Brooklyn guy I don't know but also this
video looks super dated like four by
three aspect ratio old-school graphics
kind of like all those worn down VHS
tapes we had to watch in high school or
if you're younger than me I don't know
whether you watch stuff on Holograms and
camps suit here looks like the one from
the first of interest movies so I guess
at some point after he got reawakened in
the 20 teens he made time to shoot this
fitness challenge video and when Peter
brags to Ned about stealing cap shield
which he did in Civil War we could see
the dies character Michelle reading this
book of Human Bondage by W Somerset mom
basically it's a book about being a
slave to your emotions and desires which
makes sense for Michelle since we really
only see her be sarcastic and
emotionally detached and there's also
this great benefit of an adjustable
Spider Man suit it can fit people of
different sizes giving us this awesome
shot of Ned yeah and before I move on we
get this quick shot of Peter and Ned
building some kind of tech at school
it's hard to tell exactly what it is but
based on the red and yellow colors this
could be some stark Iron Man tech maybe
part of Peters new homemade suit that he
has to engineer after he loses the one
that star cable okay moving on
the powerful like stark they don't care
about us world's changing boys time we
change too these weapons are crazy
dangerous missing Peter forget the
flying monster guy there are people who
handle this sort of thing illegal
weapons Barry was a 230 you missed it
so in this section we see more of the
vulture and some of the people he works
with now his words here kind of echo
some of the political sentiments from
recent years specifically the 99
percenters who argue that the rich and
powerful 1% financial elite in America
controlled too much wealth and influence
you know like the ego maniacs who insist
on putting their names on every
skyscraper in New York City wrong
egomaniac we actually see Avengers tower
in this trailer followed by a news
report showing Tony Stark in the words
damage control so what's going on here
so after the events of Civil War and the
past Avengers and Iron Man movies Stark
has been criticized for causing billions
of dollars of collateral damage so now
he has decided to invest his own money
and take over the cleanup operation and
damage control is actually the name of a
Marvel comic series that follows a crew
cleaning up after the superhero
conflicts working in for a company
co-owned by Tony Stark and Wilson Fisk
and damage control was actually going to
be adapted into a TV series by ABC
meanwhile NBC has a similar concept with
powerless a workplace comedy set in the
DC Universe but start taking over this
damage control has put vulture and his
crew out of the job because they would
scavenge through this wreckage find
super tech parts and bring them back to
the tinkerer to make new weapons that
they can use so I guess that's an
example of a one-percenter screwing over
the little guy but in this case the
little guy was up to no good anyway and
I love the vultures look here this pilot
jacket with an excessively fluffy collar
to make him look even more like his
appearance in the comics this section
also gives us a close-up on the vultures
wings which look and sound amazing they
look like a mix of Falcons wings Stark
type repulsors and the green Goblin's
glider which kind of makes sense because
the vulture is the scavenger who would
have gotten his tech from existing parts
it actually seems like this movie is
setting up that parallel between the
vulture and Peter Parker who does a
similar thing with his own tech there's
also this fun moment on the ferry with
spider-man joking that they missed the
illegal weapons ferry so I'm guessing
that's what these guys are doing here
transporting some new illegal tech
weapons created by the tanker earth and
before I move on we get this amazing
no-look web bomb which kind of feels
like Peter doing his best impression of
Tony Stark from the first Iron Man
and I love the way spider-man's eyes
narrow kind of like he's doing that cool
stare as he's like showing off his move
all right moving on
[Applause]
whoa this all looks awesome so first you
can see the vultures wings smashing out
of a car meaning that while this was all
going on he was hiding in a car waiting
to surprise attack we also see this
massive blast that slices the ferry in
half which we saw in the last trailer
but now there's even more of the scene
with spider-man desperately trying to
web the ferry back together as if he's
stitching a wound and an Iron Man swoops
in to save the day with a new suit
design and these propulsion drones that
assist him in pushing the ferry back
together now some people are a little
frustrated that this trailer might have
shown too much of the scene like not
just the interesting looking dilemma of
spider-man trying to web together a
ferry sliced in half but also the cool
way that that problem gets solved with
Ironman like that part kind of seemed
like it was meant to be a reveal and if
you think about it it would kind of be
like if the trailer for spider-man 2 in
2004 included not just the shots of Doc
Ock on the runaway train but
spider-man's successfully stopping the
train like sure it looked cool but now
you've taken a bit of a suspense out of
this moment so yeah I kind of agree with
the frustration but again there may be
other cool aspects to this scene that we
haven't seen yet like maybe the ferry
hits an iceberg also I'm pretty sure
this sequence will be somewhere early on
or in the middle of the movie because
this is where Peter Parker loses a suit
and we know a lot of the movie will take
place after that point and really come
on guys these days pretty much every
superhero trailer is a little
overzealous with reveals especially when
there's an opportunity to sell a new toy
months before the movie premieres so I
guess if you want to be completely
surprised don't watch trailers or just
watch the guardians of the galaxy
trailers like James Gunn doesn't tell us
anything in those okay let's move on
what if somebody had died I was just
trying to be like you I want you to be
better I'm gonna need the suit back well
I'm nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it
I screwed up you need to stop carrying
the weight of the world on your
shoulders okay so here we see what I
think will be the main dramatic turn of
the movie Peter getting his suit
confiscated by Stark and being forced to
rely on his own resourcefulness to build
his own DIY suit which is great like one
of the best things about Peter Parker's
character is his craftiness and
creativity and what he's like is just a
normal kid in fact this was one of the
things that I think made spider-man 2 so
great like all that character
development when Peter stopped wearing
the suit also I love this mentoring line
from start but nothing without this suit
if you're nothing without this shoot
then you shouldn't have it now Peter
doesn't realize it but Stark is
referencing his exchange with cap back
in the first Avengers movie big man in a
suit of armor take that off what are you
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist see stark knows that the
suit doesn't make the man the first Iron
Man movies showed that the character
underneath the mask has to be compelling
someone already heroic and I think
that's the goal of this spider-man movie
establishing Peter Parker as someone we
want to root for like how each of the
other Avengers solo films did that
moving on want you to understand I'll do
anything
protect my family I know you know what
I'm talking about
so don't mess with me
because I'll kill you and everybody you
look okay in this section we get more
confrontations between Peter and the
vulture and I love how his wings can fly
independently again kind of like green
Goblin's glider but also like the Iron
Man suits so not only will Peter have to
fight the man Adrian
Toomas but also a separate drone machine
version of them too there's also more
shots of this fight with the Shocker in
the school bus yard which I gotta say is
a really cool location for this fight it
embodies the contrast between Peters
adult problems these super-powered
criminals while he bounces off things
from his life as a kid the school buses
next there's this amazing shot on the
Coney Island Beach with the vulture
lifting Peter by his hoodie and if you
look closely you can see the vultures
arms controlling the movement of the
corresponding wing so kind of like doc
Ock's extra arms these wings are really
multi-purpose and real quick there's
this shot of lizallen kissing Peter at
the homecoming dance
meaning spider-man homecoming will
actually center around a homecoming at
school and I'm sure it'll just be an
uneventful dance with no superhero
action jazz getting all these kids
nights are gonna be ruined all right
moving on
[Music]
a guy is still out there I've just got
to do this on my own
right here there's more shots of this
attack on the Washington Monument with
Michelle finally showing some concern
over something they really your friends
Michelle or did you just run out of
pretentious books to read and I love how
the spider-man spider emblem on a suit
is also multi-purpose in addition to
tightening and releasing the suit it can
freakin fly off of him and yeah spiders
don't fly at least I hope they don't but
this is still very cool like I don't
know what it's doing or where it's going
maybe Peters just sending it off as a
spy drone or another remote web bomb or
maybe just a spoof Liz as she's falling
down the elevator shaft not a good time
and then these great shots of spider-man
refusing to let vulture escape clinging
to him as he gets dragged up way above
New York City and just like that fairy
shot Peter is shown in this desperate
impossible situation with this Statue of
Liberty in the background like it's
supposed to be a symbol of hope and
Peter webs the vulture to this jet
nearly sucking both of them into the jet
engine almost an Edna mode from the
incredible situation good thing they
don't have capes but what exactly is
this aircraft like this engine isn't on
a wing it's on the top of the craft and
by the look of it it's been previously
damaged with this jagged scar across the
hall and the engine already on fire so
in case you were wondering that small
burst of flames is not the vulture
getting sucked in come on they're gonna
ruin your life with this trailer anyway
my best guess of what's going on the
vulture damaged this aircraft whatever
it is but spider-man is trying to force
them to go down with the ship but then
this final section gives us a little
more context just don't do anything
stupid
all right yeah so yeah now it seems like
Peter has to bail on catching vulture
and now he has to figure out how to land
a damaged aircraft over the city moving
the flaps manually to control its
direction and this trailer kind of
laughs it off as the sort of dramatic
trouble that Peter promised dark-eyed
wouldn't get into but when you think
about it
airplanes crashing over New York City is
a super high-stakes situation for every
possible reason really I just love how
spider-man homecoming looks like it's
putting Peter Parker in all kinds of
stress the stresses of high school the
stress of superhuman threats and the
stress of the broader superhero world
that he desperately wants to be a part
of and I think this balance is really
the key to bringing home spider-man 2
what we love about the character okay
those are all the interesting things I
noticed in this trailer and if I didn't
cover some stuff it's because I already
talked about in my other breakdown of
the first trailer so go check that out
and let me know what you think in the
comments and if you like this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rock stars for this sort of in-depth
coverage of all kinds of Marvel content
also please share this video and if you
really like new rock stars you can
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much to all of our current patrons you
guys are awesome especially Kenny Smith
you can hit me up on twitter at EA vas
with any thoughts or predictions you
have about spider-man homecoming for all
the new rock stars on Twitter at new
rock stars for updates on their videos
alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]